the live and Alive tour is off and
running St Louis I will see you on
August 4th and 5th La local show here
August 11th Tampa Florida August 18th
and 19th with Steve Simone Springfield
Missouri September 1st and 2nd Tulsa
Oklahoma September 15th and 16th Phoenix
Arizona September 29th and 30th Salt
Lake City I'll see you all October 27th
and the 28th in San Francisco California
I'm coming back December 8th and 9th get
your tickets to all shows at
ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media and again thank you guys
thank you for being here thank you for
supporting this show Please Subscribe it
really helps it's a free way to help the
show it means a lot to us continue to
support that special out there y'all
thank you so much
um I look
you know you you do all this yourself
you put it out there and then you just
have to move on so thank you guys for uh
sticking around supporting and sharing
and all that and if you gotta have more
of this then I am telling you you have
got to have the patreon it's called the
Honeydew with y'all and I do this same
show with y'all and y'all have the
wildest stories I've ever heard I love
my job every week I I say I don't know
where how we gonna top that and we top
it every week I'm hearing something else
double lung transplants
uh hostage situations where they get
away and kill the the uh the whatever
the enemy it's crazy
it's crazy it's five bucks a month and
if you or someone you know has a story
that has to be heard please submit it to
honeydew podcast gmail.com all right if
you're looking sorry let me say it like
this if you're looking for a a new
podcast to listen to listen to my old
podcast to crab Feast it's a seven and a
half year library of everybody you know
and love in comedy today's guest
included I said how many you did at
least one he got upset because he said
he did about three and I bet it's
probably two I'll bet it's probably at
least one though is
I will be in Tampa Florida August 18th
and 19th Steve Simone coming with me for
that one all right it's gonna be a fun
show Tampa get out there Springfield
Missouri never been there to do comedy
September 1st and 2nd Tulsa Oklahoma
September 15th and 16th one stopped in
Tulsa Oklahoma on a drive across the
country bought a uh an iguana bought a
baby iguana took it back home yeah uh it
was a good little lizard sold it in the
end when I moved so uh come out get your
tickets around sickler.com uh I'm gonna
tell you about that real quick all
tickets at roncito.com uh now we're
highlighting the low lights over here
I'm already talking to our guest today
because I'm just very excited to have
this guy back ladies and Gentlemen
please welcome Gareth Reynolds welcome
back to the Honeydew gear thank you for
having me Ryan sold this iguana
I had an iguana and then I bought a
smaller one and we named it Izzy because
it was the fastest thing I've ever seen
in my life it was non-stop where is he
where is he where is he
okay we had a terrarium yeah let's we're
white trash that a friend built okay I
said cage so I'm even trash here well
it's part case wood wood frame uh-huh
okay all Plexiglas the top area cage
chicken wire sure you know yeah
um industry standard black light for
night white light for day it's a black
knight that they sell it to the store
ejaculated right
and then food in the bottom and stuff uh
and it had a cage he built so you could
slide it out change the poop and
everything even put in fresh poop right
yeah right we had this thing in there
and I'm moving and I just put it for
free I'm not trying to sell it this guy
comes to get it
and he's in love with it right
you could make a show about who shows up
for a free iguana it would be like to
catch a predator cast
take a Sit Darren This Is Where It gets
weird I'm not you just made me remember
this I'm not even kidding this happened
so um I'm you know whatever I'm in my
mid-20s early 20s so
um he's like you might help me carry
this thing out I was like no problem and
we put it he puts it on his roof okay
this whole it's it's six foot right
straps it all down his girlfriend's
sitting in the car in the passer's seat
nice they're they're a white couple no
he seemed nice enough he seemed like
clean-cut college kid or maybe just out
of college and
um he keeps like peeking around we're at
the back of the trunk now putting
whatever else in he keeps peeking around
and the girl's sitting in the car and
you know she said hi and I say how you
doing whatever
and um he's like I want to see something
he gives me to want to see something a
stranger and I'm seeing him peek around
there because I'm standing on that side
like what he's like
he takes this little photo album out
under his blanket in the in the trunk
and it's just all the chicks he's
[__] and cheating on his girlfriend
or wife with or whatever she is and just
showing he's like look at this one right
here this one's down in Glen Burnie I'm
like what
we need iguana room
this guy loves an iPhone oh yeah because
this is like what you know what I mean
you have to go keep keep swiping
I'm done
that's exactly what it was just one of
those little you know Pockets yeah yeah
I'm like what the [__] yeah
[__]
love to have you here yeah good to be
here before we get started please plug
promote everything Gareth Reynolds uh
all right well I got a a stand-up
special and a crowd work special both
which you can go watch on the all things
comedy YouTube page uh the crowderick
specialist called gareths volume one my
special is called England weed and the
rest you can go to my website if you
like garethrenals.com click the special
link you can find both those also my
tour dates are on there and uh I'll be
everywhere uh and then probably not sure
where I'll be when this comes out so go
to gearthrones.com for that stuff and
listen to the dollop
it's my podcast and also
your other podcast the Past Times yeah
yeah you know the name of it yeah the
past I was on it have I been on it yet
has it been released you've been on it
hasn't been released once you get the
name right we'll put it out yeah you
keep calling it time's pasta
um all right listen let's just get into
this today because you know what this
show is by the way if you haven't seen
Garrett's first episode you gotta or
last episode only episode okay yeah see
now you're being very down I can't
remember yeah
yeah I understand you're about to get
vulnerable
people like you don't remember when that
guy like ate his friend I'm like hey
there's been a lot of episodes but
you're being delicate now because you
under
undervalued my crab Feast so now you're
like yeah the last time you were here
it's only been one it was more about
less about undervying your craft Visa
more about seeing the sensitivity within
that than I wanted I didn't come I'm not
an iguana in a white trash cage right
now I'm not here to be toyed with
okay well so but afterwards come to the
trunk of my car
I got something to show you it's the
night
it's the night yeah or he would have
been like yeah yeah yeah yeah
in a file called yeah yeah she doesn't
check cat videos
um so you have a story yeah and you say
you've not this is exclusive this is
exclusive all right let's do it um yeah
I've never I actually the last time I
was here I said to you I was like I do
have one
um that I am
I've just always been really hesitant to
talk about
um
for a number of reasons
um one is that it is
a bit of a Whopper so the other is that
um well let's just get into it so
okay so the dollop my podcast starts
before that I you know like you or
anyone was really trying to I was trying
to you know get ahead and stand up and
just nobody really gave a [__]
so I really kind of fell into like
writing I just started writing I was
writing on shows and
um
and was very lucky but was still like I
want to perform but that I kind of was
like I guess that's not gonna happen or
whatever it's gonna take forever and
then the dollar pits
and then I'm like all of a sudden it it
kind of warped my mind because
you know in like the stand-up world like
you know you go clubs
you know theaters eventually like all
that hopefully yeah and the dollop just
kind of was like theaters quickly so I
real quick was just from like oh I
probably won't be performing to like oh
wow I'm like doing theaters and
so much came out of that like where I
was so kind of over stimulated and
gratified by that experience that you
know
fully was taking advantage was partying
was like you know we would sell our own
merch like after shows for the first
couple years and like you know I would
be like I would meet women after the
show like selling merch and go get
drinks and like hook up and that was
just like
and then you know you're getting like I
was getting like female attention on a
level where I was like I'd been not you
know well you know what it's like when
random women are like hey I like you and
you're like you've got the wrong General
yeah stop it I'm telling you I let me
tell you something let me take you to my
car after this
is a true story I've never hooked up on
the road that's never not one time
that's because you don't want to exactly
yeah well it's not that I don't have an
urge but also I think two things mostly
all right number one I don't want a road
baby sure you know what I mean I don't
want some kid I can't have or be with
you couldn't handle an iguana right two
of them yeah I mean I've been off more
than I can yeah
STDs sure always freaked me the [__] out
sure always yeah so I also am worried
about being robbed those are my top
three okay those don't listen well
you're gonna like I'm in Fort Wayne
Indiana and you want to go back to where
or me to go to your place next thing I
know Bing Bang Boom two guys come in on
you around the corner you're all
splitting the money three ways I that's
my mindset about things in life so
that's a very smart way of approaching
it I did not have that way of
approaching it listen in 20 years I've
never done that on the road oh dude I I
mean women when I like when I date
girlfriends they don't believe it at all
and I'm like I'm telling you it's not
happened well okay so
so there are literally like you know
there were there were just like women
like just you know popping in my DMs
just like you know aggressive and I I
while I don't think I ever had that I
didn't have a small modicum of that
issue I just all of a sudden was like oh
[__] like I could hook up with this girl
I could hook up with that girl so I
started talking to this one woman
through DMs on Instagram and
um we go back and forth and she's
whatever nice and you know sending me
like animal videos and [__] like that
and so that's pretty good for me and um
so I'm like yeah let's get a drink you
know I've gone out I really wouldn't go
out with like a lot of women come in can
I just stop you there for a second is
this a local lady okay this is not a
woman you've met at a show or you're
planning to meet this show okay all
right but when I what so I go and at the
time I'm working on
um Arrested Development which the hours
are nuts you wrote on that yeah oh hell
yeah dude yeah so and hours are totally
nuts so you do kind of you are kind of
like sacrificing your social life for
that show
um to some extent you know and and they
were very nice they let me like go off
and do shows and stuff like that but
that wasn't like free time it was like
my schedule is pretty pretty crammed and
um so I go meet her for a drink and um
you know we start talking and
um she is very like you know she knows
the podcast and she's lives part-time in
Vegas and um
you know is
is talking a lot about like her exes and
she seems to have dated a number of
people who are like in the business and
stuff like that but but I'm also just
like not thinking in any realm of
anything other than like this is gonna
maybe be a hookup and
um and I'm not even sure if we're gonna
hook up
um but I live close to where we go and
get a drink and as she's driving me back
I wasn't and this kind of sounds dickish
but I'm just being honest like I wasn't
thinking like oh we're gonna go hook up
I was kind of thinking like ride home
and we'll see what happens but she was
excited and she was excited to meet my
cat which has happened before where I'm
like my cat is like
become arguably a bigger draw than me
not even just on the road but also you
know like with that and so and so I'm
kind of like okay whatever so we go up
to my place we have a couple more drinks
anyway we end up hooking up and she
meets my cat and he's so down to earth
and um oh yeah
I met her cat and um
and so I'm very clear up front like I do
not want anything serious I don't have
time for anything serious but but we're
starting to hook up you know whatever
how old is she she's maybe five six
years younger than me okay so you know
she's 20.
um no uh but but she's a little younger
than me and um
so that's going on but then I'm still
also getting you know DMS from from
random women and there's this one woman
on Twitter who I start messaging with
and um she's like a uh like a makeup
artist who lives in Burbank and um and
we start messaging and it gets very
sexual very quickly and um I'm sure this
is probably her first time doing
something obviously yeah yeah this is
good you're gonna feel like all your
fears are unwarranted after this
and um and so so it gets sexual very
quickly I have no idea what you're about
to say so the one that I gone out with
she she told me that she had worked like
you know in like the
shall I say
um sex industry lightly like it kind of
been like a dominatrix type person for a
couple years back there whatever that
doesn't bother me I did the naughty show
with Sam Tripoli like I was like that's
fine that's why that's industry standard
that's right yeah and um and so she gets
sexual very quickly and she's like
talking about like right away sex and
all this stuff and and it starts off
okay and then right away I'm like this
is like a lot early and then she reveals
that she's married but it's an open
relationship and I'm like I don't feel
very comfortable with that and um and
then she's like telling me stuff about
how she went to a sex club and she's
like I got DP'd last night and I'm like
yeah and I'm and I'm like a camera
operator uh but uh but so I'm like right
away I'm like that's that's that's one
too many four years ago yeah like yeah
fresh
you mean hours ago so so I'm like no so
I'm like no to that
um which two by the way yeah there's one
available which two yeah uh she was like
do you want to see my book here you go
I'll flip through that I was like I
really
um
so okay so right so I'm like turned off
by that situation but and then I'm still
sort of seeing
um Michelle is the one who I was like
I've been going out with and um so I'm
still sort of seeing Michelle and then
the one on on Twitter is this woman
named Angela and she's like
she one day is like I just realized we
have someone in common in our lives and
I'm like who she's taking days to get
back I'm going who is it and she's like
I've worked with Michelle I'm a makeup
artist Michelle's modeled for stuff like
I know her and I'm like oh and she's
like I saw her at a party and we just
got to talking and I told her that you
and I were flirting and I'm like well
Jesus Christ
so again I'm not like dating Michelle
but I feel like when I see her inside
her yes yeah she's been inside my place
I've been inside her place right yeah
and I've never seen her home and uh and
so
so I like kind of contextualize it when
I'm when I'm talking to her I'm like oh
yeah you know and she's like no it's
cool you can do whatever and I'm like
yeah I know but I'm not flirting with
her like she told me she got DP'd and
she is you know and then along the way
she's like I'm pregnant but that doesn't
matter like stuff like and I'm just
going I'm not like this is just crazy so
um
so so whatever this goes on for a while
and then um
she keeps messaging me Angela keeps
messaging me and I keep kind of ignoring
it and then Michelle like I said lives
part-time in Vegas then there's the
Vegas shooting right and um
and Michelle I go to bed early because
of Arrested Development not because I
was arrested uh and I go to and I go to
bed early and I wake up and she's like
hey I'm gonna get the Mandalay Bay all
this stuff there's been a shooting all
this [__] and then like I read she was
at the well I write back I don't hear
anything so I'm like what the [__] you
know and um Angela messages me and she
goes have you heard from Michelle like
we're trying to find her like I'm
talking to her ex because she had a kid
she's like I'm talking to her ex about
whatever and I'm I'm like no I haven't
so I give her my number I go here's my
number because I'm not gonna be able to
check my phone I go message me if you
know like text message me if there's any
update and I'm worried all day and then
eventually Michelle text me and she's
like I'm okay I was you know I got like
trampled like so many people were
running like I got a concussion my phone
broke all this [__]
something like holy [__] you know but
now I've given um Angela my number right
so
so Michelle continues to be like very
helpful like I'm going to Australia and
um you know it's just like a good
presence and all that stuff and so I go
to Australia to tour and okay so part of
it as well is that there had been like a
Facebook group started just about me
um like whatever like like a fan page
like a female fan page essentially right
wow yeah it was like two members but
still counts stuff I had to go through I
should point out I'm the one who started
it but that counts yeah uh so I'm the
administrator of this site but um
so so I'm in Australia and um
and Michelle's like oh yeah I noticed
this like fan site or whatever and I
really didn't know about it and I was
like you know do whatever I don't give a
[__] and um
so like I said Michelle as a kid when
I'm leaving Australia
um a couple of things happen one is that
Angela is really putting the pressure on
me to meet up with her she's now texting
me like all the time when are we gonna
meet up this is [__] why are you
meeting up with Michelle like she's like
I'm way hot or all this stuff and I'm
just like ignoring it for the most part
every now and then just being like you
know relax whatever leave me alone and
um
does she know that the uh what's the
other girl's name again Michelle that
her relationship is open and stuff is
that why she worried well Michelle so
Michelle's the Instagram girl who I went
out with right Angela's the Twitter girl
she knows yeah she's which one did you
have sex with again Michelle all right
um and so she knows Angela's crazy she's
like yeah she's wild like I've known her
for you know a few years and like in
this world
um so when I land
um Michelle's texting me
Angela's like got a new gear she's
[__] losing her mind she's posting
these pictures of me that I didn't want
to tell you were out there but it's like
nude modeling that I did and you know I
they're out there I did it under a
different name she found him and she's
posting them tagging you and being like
you know Gareth what sleeps with this
girl and this is his kind of girl and
just stuff where I'm like looking on
Twitter and I'm going holy [__] what
[__] you know and um as well as she
tells me directly Angela that she posted
in that Facebook group that I was the
father of her kid Michelle's kid what
and this picture
and I'm like what the [__] are you doing
and it's all to leverage me to go out
with her
and I'm just like I'm not going to go
out with it well obviously I'm married
yeah and I'm just like no [__] leave
me alone you know like [__] off and so
Michelle and I are talking about it how
it's out of control and she's like I
blocked her you should block her
and so I just block her number you know
and I'm like all right whatever which
I've never done before
um so I blocked her number and I was
like okay whatever I asked her to take
that picture down from that Facebook
group but it was like stressing me out
obviously
um especially the Twitter stuff
seeing all these posts well let me I'm
not super intelligent uh is it slander
what is it when you're falsely claiming
that someone's the father yeah is it
slander I can't remember I think it is
it slander yeah okay yeah so so it is
and I'm like I'm flagging it trying to
get Twitter to take it down all this
[__] Michelle meanwhile's like I feel
really bad that I didn't tell you about
this I'm like I don't give a [__] you
know
but then about three hours later I mean
I just landed like from that like space
flight yeah and um a few hours later she
texts Angela text me again from a
different number she's like why did you
block me all this stuff
and I'm just like what the [__] so I
just blocked that one right I'm like
she's using her friend's number or
whatever
so or husbands or husbands yeah or you
know one of the DP guys there's a lot of
options for it you can get a phone
um so so I blocked that then like later
there's another text from another number
and I'm just like what the [__] is going
on and Michelle's like same happening to
me texting me from random numbers we
both just keep blocking what's the
messages that are going to Michelle just
I mean like stuff that's just like
you're such a [__] like you you like
anger anger just like I'm posting these
pictures all because she got you and
yeah all because I like I think I was
like we'll get a drink and then we
didn't right and so it's all it's like
it's non-stop too right so then like I
said I'm working on arrested
and
she is just like blowing up my phone
she's calling me from random numbers
non-stop I block the number doesn't
matter new number texting me from random
numbers block that doesn't matter new
number never ending numbers middle of
the night texts hey hi what are you up
to are you up oh hey I just found a
picture of you on the naughty show I'm
gonna post it and say that it's this and
that and she's like posting all this
stuff on my Twitter and [__] so I'm like
it's like a full-time job of me being
like trying to get this [__] down from
my Twitter stressing out feeling like
people are seeing this and again this is
like right when like I'm feeling like
some momentum and I'm just going this
person is just not I mean like a
full-time [__] job which I have so
it's hard for me so I would sit there
and I'd have my phone like there and I'd
be like working yeah and then just see
my phone light up and you know when you
can tell that it's not a name it's a
number and I just see a number and I'd
be like son of a [__]
and it would be like you know 20 30 text
calls a day and the same thing's
happening to Michelle and she's like
what you should do is because she's a
angel is a makeup artist
she's like you should tell someone at
the studio you're working with or at
least threaten her that you're gonna
have her name put on like a blacklist so
that she doesn't work and so I do that
I'm like you know if you keep doing this
[__] I'm gonna I'm gonna do this get you
put on this list
and she backs off for a minute
um but then comes right back keeps doing
I would get a few days of silence and
I'd be like maybe it's interrupting my
sleep and it's like well me when we meet
up it's all we're talking about like
because we're kind of getting a little
closer because of this situation you
know but it's all we're talking about
it's all strategy
and I feel like
such a deep level of shame that
maybe because I have invited this person
into my world and it was to what you
were saying before it was so careless it
was like such I'm just saying well I
want to have a drink yeah but it was
like and she's posting screenshots of
our conversation where I said she goes I
what have you ever done anything great
and I said I slept with a dominatrix a
few nights ago or something like that
she's posting that going this is what
kind of dirt bag this guy is
and then still hitting you up hey what
are you doing it's all yeah we need to
get a drink when are we getting a drink
yeah when will you get a drink I'll if
you get a drink with me this will stop
you know
and um and I don't know necessarily it
was just so it was it just kind of like
blew my brain out
and I really was unable to
kind of get my footing back underneath
me I was working I was so distracted she
was trying to like log into my Twitter
she was trying to like they were talking
and a little trying to log in yeah you
know when you get the verification yes
I'm getting the verification code over
and over again I'm going what the [__]
you know
um
and so and I don't really necessarily
know I mean I just felt really
embarrassed by it I felt like I was
careless
and my world was kind of being like
blown up by it and um
so this is going on and on and on and
every time I block a number there's a
new one and then I'm in San Diego for a
weekend of shows and I
um I give the club Angela's picture I'm
like do not let this person in you know
now can I ask you this this has gone on
for a while at this point yeah this is
probably like she doesn't show up at any
of your local shows many because you're
working so much partially that and when
I did do a show she showed up and had
like taken a picture of me on stage but
didn't approach you didn't approach just
posted it later so you knew she was
there yeah yeah so so now you've given
this club her photo so I'm like don't
let this person at that level we're at
that level yeah and and so one of the
people that I let in is like my buddy
from high school who was like a Tech Guy
and um you know like you know whatever
works an online advertising is one of my
best friends and he's kind of helping me
get stuff taken down constantly and all
that and um so Michelle's like on that
weekend she's like I'm gonna try to like
talk to her calmly because I know her a
little bit and I'm gonna pitch that she
dates this guy I know who's on this
Showtime show Gigolos which I'd never
heard of but it's like whatever like cut
dudes with big dongs and uh like us and
um and so she's like she does all that
right and she's she's basically like she
went for it
she's into him they talked on the phone
and I'm like [__] beautiful
hallelujah or Alleluia sometimes I had
the H is there an H I go with the H
thank you and um
that's what the Jesus H Christ is for
interesting thank you and um so
so then Angela texted me she goes hey
sends me a picture of this dude like
naked she's like this is the new guy I'm
going with he's way more sexual you're
kind of a cold fish and I'm just like
what the [__]
so so she's and she like because that
blocked her number she's like hey it's
Angela like this is the dude or whatever
how many numbers dude endless hundreds
how many how do you do that at the end
of the day thousand how do you do that
so it's from this this it was from this
company called text now in Canada
we eventually found out and it's
basically like a number generator and
there's ways to do it now too and it's
just like for your same phone you can
generate generate generate an endless
text from endless numbers endless I mean
you think about spam calling and [__]
like that it's like that that technology
but now it's being utilized for like
total harassment right and my buddy
figured it out and so anytime I'd be
getting a message you know sometimes I'd
be like hey this is Gavin Newsom and I'm
like that could be her my buddy be like
no that's Gavin news or it's supposed to
be Gavin news
um so so I'm very like we know that
right but anyway she's like I'm gonna
leave you alone I'm going with this guy
so I sent it to my two buddies who I've
been talking to about this and a female
friend of mine just laughing just like
this is nuts you know and my buddies are
laughing but the female friend of mine
is like
she spelled her name differently in the
text
she's like when she said hey this is
Angela like I've just so you know I've
changed that name which is always a good
sign fair enough in a story when she's
changing names
and and I'm like you're bearing the lead
I'm like that doesn't matter it's [__]
who gives a [__] she goes as a woman I
would never misspell my own she's like
would you misspell your name and I'm
like no but whatever you know
and then they she's like
are you sure that Michelle is an Angela
and I'm like wait yeah I'm like I'm 100
Michelle like Fight Club type [__] are
we talking about right now so I'm like
there's no way so I might cause my tech
buddy we talked about that and he'd gone
through the Twitter evangela and he's
like he's like it's not he's like it's a
real User it's but you've never ever
seen Angela in person no
she'd come to stuff she texted me
Non-Stop
but no it was just harassment
so
we start talking about it and we start
going that could be possible
and then what hold on when does it hit
you where you're like all right that
Michelle could be Angela
I still think no way because Michelle is
so helpful
and also going through all the same
stuff and pictures of her being posted
that she doesn't want out there and
we're all we're both being tagged in
this stuff like it's Non-Stop
so I'm like there's no way so they're
like ask for a picture of Michelle and
Angela together and the picture of
Michelle these ones that she didn't want
release they were actually her yeah you
could definitely tell okay and they're
compromising they're like but I mean
they weren't photoshopped no okay
they're her they're totally her and um
and so I'm like hey
my friends are just for shits and
giggles asking you know because you've
you've known her for years do you have
any pictures of you two together and she
goes yeah of course I do she's like I'll
send you one tonight after your show
like okay great
um
after the show she's like I'm my hard
drive's all [__] up like I will get
some they're just old pictures whatever
I'm like okay
so
uh the next day I'm like starting to get
real anxious and she's still going like
I'm finding some
whatever
after my show my buddies like call me
and I'm like okay and I mean performing
under the rest of this I'm like what's
going on because you don't know if she's
gonna show up if you don't know I'm not
sure what's going on right
and my buddy goes call me
and I call him and he's like where are
you and I'm like in the mall where the
club is and he goes sit down
and I'm like oh boy
so sit down
and he goes
Michelle is Angela no
he goes I'm gonna send you a link to a
website devoted to Michelle
and I need you to just go through and
read about it and then call me back
and I'm like okay and he sends me this
link and it's like dozens of people
talking about how Michelle is like Satan
she tries to ruin men she tries to ruin
their lives she all she does is constant
harassment she does it through various
angles but she sets up fake people she
does all this stuff when when I'm when
these things are getting posted about me
on Twitter my DMs are like blowing up
with people like have you seen this this
woman is saying this about you like I
thought you were a good guy like
whatever all this stuff's coming in and
and when I'm reading this site about her
there's so much stuff she
it's loaded with horrible things about
her this person who I'm like she's my
hero my help my helper you've had sex
with her yeah and yeah I mean we don't
need to keep coming back to that I feel
like you're really hung up at your cat
yes she met my cat I mean enough better
for you well he should have judged her
the animal just must have an innate
ability
um but he's [__] purring he's like ah
this is cool liquid IV the number one
powdered hydration brand in America is
now available in sugar-free years in the
making hydration multiplier sugar-free
uses a proprietary zero sugar hydration
solution with no artificial sweeteners
they've got tons of great flavors and
even some new ones like white peach and
sea Berry the travel packs make it easy
to use daily even if I'm on the road one
stick of liquid IV and 16 ounces of
water hydrate you two times faster and
more efficiently than water alone liquid
IV combines science back zero sugar
technology with the Brand's commitment
to delicious real flavor no artificial
sweeteners and zero sugar with a
proprietary amino acid allulose blend
for a sweet taste without the calories
or raised blood glucose levels you get
from sugar contains eight vitamins and
nutrients for everyday Wellness with
three times the electrolytes of leading
sports drinks plus it's non-GMO free
from gluten dairy and soy real people
real flavor real hydrating now
sugar-free grab your liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugar-free and bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
code honeydew it checkout that's 20 off
of anything you order when you use promo
code honeydew at liquid iv.com now let's
get back to the do
um so the site has just got but this
woman went through the lengths of
posting compromising pictures of herself
and generating number after number and
then going so far as to show you text
she's getting yeah screenshots
constantly
screenshots after screenshots from
random numbers like when you're actually
doing the math you're going how the [__]
does someone even have time for this
yeah but as I'm reading the website it's
like there's so much stuff among them
that she's not allowed to go to the
State of Florida she's banned from
Florida
because she created
where people hold up liquor stores with
alligators yeah and that State's like
nah they're killing their own kids down
there being allowed to do a bar rescue
bar pre-save
being like yeah
our America within America she can't go
too
because she like filed a fake missing
person's report and kept it going for
days what wasted police funds all this
[__]
um
crazy [__] like that right
also these little things she was telling
me before like who the father of her
child was and and and and they've never
seen God yeah so that's all this is
there's no kid and all that's even did
you ever see a child or husband photo
from Angela
no okay so she didn't make up a whole
family because that'd be nappy crazy no
yeah okay but but there were lots of I
mean again my buddy was like this is a
real person you know because we had
talked about it but but so now I'm like
in this mall in San Diego and I'm like
holy [__] what the [__] am I gonna do
um meanwhile she's like hey I found a
picture and she sends me a picture of
her with someone who's not Angela she's
like she's had a lot of work done since
then and I'm like you know like like she
had like a face SWAT like she had like
the Face-Off Nicholas Kate like she
swapped her face she's like she touched
a Vaz during a line just in her third
her face became a different head
what like insulting but I just go oh
okay yeah that yeah okay I'm good I was
worried for a minute but there you and
her for sure are on a boat
and um how often are you seeing Michelle
physically
how long is this time six months
probably at about three months and uh
I'm seeing her probably once I pre total
I probably went out with her like seven
times
and a lot of it was like I said I mean
it's not the best light to be reflected
in but it was like I'd be like I'm gonna
be done with work at 11 30. she's like
I'll meet you at 11 30. I'd be like fine
you know it was really all I had time
for so I was like okay
um
so but yeah so for the amount of time I
was talking to her a lot more you never
went to her place no
now I wonder how telling that would have
been there's a lot of stuff you'll find
in retrospect that's quite telling
there's a lot of of courses of course of
course of course next time hit me up
I'll be like listen man you're gonna get
robbed You're Gonna Get Money my club is
a great cop because I'm in a parking lot
drinking a beer and then dropping it to
myself it's literally what is happening
you know what I mean I'm just in a
basement beating myself and people like
what I'm like what are you looking at
um
so now I'm like what the [__] yeah cause
now you gotta get we gotta address it
and get the [__] out of here we gotta
figure it out
I think partially because
I'm so rattled
I am trying to not you [__] lie I'm
trying a Homer Simpson into the bushes
yeah but also this is a unstable person
and going hard and aggressive may be the
wrong move
it even though you want to be like what
the [__] yeah it made me a lot of things
I'm about to say made me you know and
I'm not trying to like gender this issue
but when I think about like women in
situations of abuse or you know where
there is like sexual Advance any of that
stuff that come out 20 years later or
they don't pursue a charge and dudes are
always like well why the [__] didn't she
mention it like the day after this
situation makes me so understanding to
that again not trying to say what I went
through as like abuse fair enough but
there's this level of like this is abuse
though it is but it's not like I'm just
not trying to be like
women I'm evicted you know what I mean
like me too you know like I'm just
saying that curse
that's terrible Gareth Reynolds running
for Senate women yeah
but because because a you're ashamed and
B you're like I don't want to [__]
I'm not trying to go back and like rip
the cobras head off well that's awesome
this is insane insane insane insane the
fact that
you know uh what is it what's the Ace
Ventura Lois is Einhorn or whatever um
I'm having my iron harness you are
having an eye Hornet space and all the
little like your mind is blown in this
telling this is like I'm like I can't
process yeah cause you got to go step by
step the full time
it's the full-time you still gotta go
perform you're still on your weekend
doing shows
slept in my car one of the days because
I was like I told her which hotel I was
in like I mean it's just like rattled me
and um okay so now I know right so I'm
basically your friend is your enemy I'm
trying to Homer Simpson into the bushes
I'm going hey this whole thing's
rattling me
um meanwhile
I'm calling the cops
I'm calling a lawyer
and my friend ends up putting me in
touch with a lawyer who's not in any way
associated with this type of law
but she's awesome and she's going here's
the reality
you know as I'm going through the stuff
that you're showing me she goes Michelle
as Michelle has not made a threat to you
she's been nice she's been sweet she's
been helpful
Angela from her thousand different
numbers has been harassing you you have
a case against Angela who's not real
your issue is proving that Michelle is
Angela and she's like and that's a lot
harder than you might think that it is I
go to the cops the cops are like
so the problem is this woman is trying
to [__] you a lot and I'm like yeah that
sounds like the cops yeah and I'm like
yeah officer and he's like I think a lot
of guys would really like that problem
and I'm like bro oh my God take this
down to what's up
literally made me be like oh my God so
like so I'm like okay not cop the lawyer
is like you've got to be able to prove
that it's her which is possible but for
now I'm just trying to get away so I
start telling Michelle stuff like oh
yeah you know oh also I go through those
DMS that I'm getting every time she
posts stuff and I'm going that's her
that's her that so she's heightening my
stress by being like hey I saw this
tweet hey I saw this thing hey all this
stuff and I'm like oh a hundred people
have seen this well no she's created 100
you know sock puppet accounts and and
stuff that now again I recognize so
easily but at the time I was just like
nobody do this it's crazy it's not an
existence if you're doing this and um
so I'm like yeah I'm kind of going
through I'm like I'm a little too
stressed out and I'm talking to a shrink
and the shrink is basically like I
should probably just try to back off
from this whole situation she's like oh
great who's your shrink I'm actually
looking for a shrink I'm like nah I
don't think we should say the same shirt
my friends are getting
um text messages now from these numbers
she got my friends numbers she's texting
my friends being like hey this is Gareth
this is my new phone number hey you know
whatever my friends are getting calls
from random numbers my friends are
getting calls from my number at 3am
which I was like how can you do that you
can do that just spoofing my number
[__] friends three four in the why
are you calling me you woke my kid up
all the I'm just going it's not me but
again the I'm so embarrassed
now even more so because now I'm like
well the one fine horn is you know
Einhorn is Finkle so I'm trying to and
um
and it's going on and on I'm trying to
just get away from it it's not stopping
it's going crazy but I still have
Michelle being like because I haven't
told her hey are you okay like the day
that she posts a bunch of stuff about me
on Twitter again hey did is Angela
posted anything about you lately no I'm
good you know but I'm like you [__]
lunatic you crazy like you're and she's
like totally getting off on the ability
to be like stress him out is he okay
um
so
as I'm backing away this is nuts as I'm
backing away I am um it's still
happening and then my friend is like you
know probably a week later like hey
there's something else I gotta tell you
and it's he's found her escort profile
that's Court yes so she's an escort in
Vegas
and um
he's like it's active
so I'm like at a rest of development I
have to go into Mitch hurwitz's office
and I'm just like hey buddy you know and
he's like running the show he's like
stressed yeah yeah what's going on and
I'm like I need to go down the street to
get STD tests because I ended up
sleeping with this woman who's a sex
worker and I wasn't protected all the
time and he was like okay take a lunch
Whatever Whenever you need to take lunch
buddy go down there get the full game
but you know somehow I'm like good Lord
clean and I'll never forget the way they
ran me through the clean results it was
like are you ready for your results and
I was like I mean I get all right clean
negative and I'm like Jesus Christ I
keep expecting to be like AIDS you got
it and I'm like ah
but she's just it just in a way where I
would never know what you do have yeah
you're sitting down you know all that
like what my buddy did when he did the
route you're sitting down you Homer
Simpson in the wrong Bush Amigo yeah you
did
um
and then like I took a yoga class and
this this woman in yoga class like
somehow like recognized me and we
started talking and so I'm like all
right well I'm gonna take her out and
I'm like still this is like
I'm kind of this I'm probably about five
months in at this point and I'm sorry
and how much
at this point in the five months how
much is Rachel still hitting you up
Angela I mean Angela still hitting you
up don't Rachel me sorry we'll get to
her all right um Austin still yeah so
Michelle's still doing the Rachel thing
all this time Angela it's sorry they're
all made up names I think they are um
but yes yes still still aggressively
hitting you with Andrew as aggressive
but it's almost like I'll be like six
days not letting it go six days without
it and I'm starting to go maybe maybe
and then it's like back
maybe but during that six days you're
hearing from Michelle yeah okay yeah
Michelle is trying to have an army have
you seen Michelle since you found this
because I I talked to the attorney I
talked to was like you cannot meet up
with Michelle again because Michelle had
a history first of all has a [__]
record second of all man from Florida
bro I mean come on we're talking liquor
store alligators she and has a record
and and some of it is like abuse claims
and and she's like what's gonna happen
is because Michelle's like I want to
give you this gift if we're not going to
talk I want to give you this gift should
push him for this gift I'm going no you
know she's like you meet up with her she
[__] does Fight Club herself says hey
you [__] hit her so I'm like nope
nope nope so I'm just skirting skirting
skirting like not gonna meet up with you
and and it's it's awkward and it's it's
making Angela [__] worse you know
because Angela's the alter ego so
Angela's in more of an attack mode and
um
straight up Jacqueline hi [__] this is
nuts and so um so this this woman in
yoga class so so we go out right and
after we go out I follow her on
Instagram the next day that later that
day she texts me and she goes look dude
if you have a girlfriend you can just
[__] tell me don't take someone out
when you have a girlfriend sends me a
screenshot of a random number
and it's just like hey this is gareth's
girlfriend I know that you went out with
him
um or I know that you guys are talking
you should stop and I'm just like I
don't even have the words to be like
that's not a girlfriend I have a stalker
I I have an iron and Finkle who [__] you
know I'm like okay godspeed
um but it's it's like that continuing
that sort of [__] it's like that all the
time other friends of mine anyone I
couldn't follow anyone on [__]
Instagram because she was going at me
um and it's yeah just going on like that
for for ages and ages again still
hundreds of texts called hundreds then I
met arrested wait one second when Angela
calls she never leaves a voicemail no
not once no and you call back and it's
like there's it's like some you know I'm
gonna it's text now and these are in the
middle of the night so in the middle of
the night I'd like hit my phone and be
like oh good nothing all right go
and then be up so I'm not sleeping I'm
not eating I'm [__] drinking white
wine like a like a housewife like a real
housewife I'm like I am like friends of
mine would just be like hey here's a six
pack of Trader Joe wine I'd be like
that's nice to see anyone ever did for
me you know as I was like emaciated yet
bloated at the same time and then um
Michelle's like she's looking for your
home address now keep my Michelle's been
to my place so she knows my home address
and Angela's not [__] real but this
is like I'm like there's an escalation
here and then she goes she knows it she
figured it out sends me a screenshot he
lives here you know in in wherever I
live is she posting that no but she's
just saying to her now I know where he
lives so I race home from I go to Mitch
again Mitch hurwitz arrested and I just
go hey so now this star okay yeah go go
you know like my updates to him or he's
like I shouldn't have invited this guy
um get home
[__] think that there's gonna be some
[__] up [__] going on and um
nothing I put like a [__] dresser in
front of my door I sleep with a knife by
my bed I end up getting an Airbnb for
like 10 days
and again I know it's all [__] but
I'm still like I don't know and during
that 10 days is Michelle still hitting
you yeah yes are you okay where are you
did you did you talking on the phone
I'm just trying to I'm trying to keep it
as little contact as possible but in as
okay of places I still feel like you
think I'm both of these people no no no
I don't I don't oh she would say things
like that and I go no no because I'm
again I'm just my
I'm just trying to Homer Simpson in the
[__] Bush and um and so if someone
doesn't know that reference they're
gonna the hell's who is this man what is
this man talking about but I'm just
trying to I'm just trying to sneak out
on this [__] and um
and then it and then it stops over the
holidays it stops she takes like she
stops like December nothing
for like whatever two months I'm like
this is [__] amazing I think it's
done I'm sleeping again I'm like eating
properly I'm even like starting to work
out a little bit I mean I saw a picture
of myself on Arrested Development when I
was doing this [__] and I was like Jesus
Christ like wine big wine should not
have that photo because that that
slander
um
so
and then
it starts again starts up again
right after the holidays right after
holidays starts up again texts it's hey
uh my girlfriend got a text from your
number you better leave us the [__]
alone you know like a new angle so I
know she's orchestrating it but I'm like
she's shifting tactics so then I do get
a [__] lawyer and um and the lawyer
basically is like here's what you got to
do you got to go through everything and
build the case I'm friends with someone
who works in in law Loosely take this
yes so we gotta we go through everything
and we build this [__] case like
where it's just every text filing it
under what it is what laws are being
broken all that stuff and and the lawyer
is expensive as [__] as you know and I I
never experienced really a situation
like where a lawyer's like oh for sure
and then you're like that email was five
hundred dollars like I didn't know I had
heard that they were uh blood suckers
but you're paying on the quarter hour
yeah yeah for an email though like I
mean I'm just like why did I reply okay
cool you know they're like thanks like
that was the 250 thanks
um so so as I'm building this case I'm
going through this stuff and I'm like
missing [__] I'm like oh she took
pictures of my friend's house and oh she
like I just stopped checking them
eventually just because but the
threatening nature of this is escalating
and stepping up you know and um and as
I'm going through it it's [__]
traumatic and I'm I'm building this case
and we're gonna go for a restraining
order but what you need to do is prove
the [__] metadata you need to prove
that it came from this place where she
lives you need to get a [__] pi to go
where she lives and that person needs to
monitor it and be able to connect the
metadata meaning what like it pinged off
this cell tower
basically you can specifically say it
came from this [__] location okay
right because she's we know so much
Jake's couldn't they shouldn't they be
able to Ping the phone too like
specifically this device yeah but that's
like I mean think about when Apple was
like wouldn't like I can't remember what
the case was right they wouldn't give
their info you're not you're not able to
get into that [__] like
I could do it I still could prove it
it just would cost so much [__]
probably a quarter of a million dollar
and then when I'm writing on arrested
two
um someone explains the situation to
another person I work with and she goes
this happened to my friend
and my buddy goes same sort of situation
she goes the same person no so she's
done this she
has so many dudes in the business
and like tons of them what's her number
yeah well that's hard to answer honestly
get a scroll
um and so and she's like so you're
telling someone this and then they say
this my buddy is because I'm not there
he's like Garrett's not here today
because of this he's can't get out of
bed because he's like [__] losing his
body and then she says this happened to
my friends you go same situation no same
person this person did it except this
guy [__] lost his mind and like
deleted his social media and then
there's an other people she another
person was like oh she made up a fake
pregnancy with this guy she said she was
pregnant she um
was like I'm gonna go get the abortion
wouldn't go get it turned out she wasn't
pregnant so after the Christmas break
part I had to stop smoking weed like you
know when you're like unhappy you can't
smoke weed you know what's so funny yes
I whenever my worst times I smoke weed
all at the marijuana helps me Focus yes
and when I'm in bad times and I smoke it
helps me focus on the wrong the Panic
the Panic the anxiety future tripping
the the spiraling I I can't either when
I'm when I'm at my lowest and that's
what happened to me like I I was the
happiest [__] Stoner who ever stoned
and then it was just like I would take
weed for you dude completely but then
after the two-month break I'm like I
think I can smoke weed and I don't know
how this timed out I think she just got
lucky but literally the first day I
smoked weed it was NFL Sunday I was in
my bed I was like [__] it I'll take a
couple hits I had a couple rips well
watching the Falcons game and I get a
text from the random number and it goes
I hear you got someone pregnant
and I had been counting the days to when
I would be clear of that threat and it
was like coming up to it which is why I
was like I can smoke some weed
and then it was like [__] but I was also
at the point now where I was like I
don't believe anything
so
I let it go but she was still trying
every angle she could to make me be like
like and I played out the baby part in
my head like with my friends I'd War
gamed it you know I was like I'm a
[__] I'm gonna fight for full custody
is what I'm gonna do and my friends are
like who is this man right and I was
like I mean you can't have a [__] kid
living with this [__] person you know
while she's in like a bedroom like
playing Sims with comedians from like
Vegas yeah you know with their like
emotions so I'd like I wargamed it out
and then eventually stopped hearing
about it and I'm like well I think it's
[__] fake
um but again was like if it isn't let's
[__] go
um what was your conversation like with
the lady at work who's like this
happened to my friend she did not talked
to her friend did he get an attorney
um I didn't talk to him he was so [__]
up really yeah that he was like I don't
want to have I don't want to hurt an um
around I don't want to talk to anyone
about it holy [__] yeah
he he like stopped pursuing stuff for a
while two L's or one two
uh
so so and and what she said to me at
work she goes she just needs to find
another Target but I but as I'm building
this case I'm going a year two years I'm
like I'm not gonna [__] wait I'm
gonna go at it so as I'm building this
case and stuff it just kind of is
stopping again I'm about to file for
restraining orders
um you know like I'm right there but I
hate my lawyer and since then have found
a lawyer who like again is like if we
need to go we can [__] go not cheap
but and I know other people so it's like
you could get a few people on board with
this [__]
um
but
as it's happening it's just stopping and
I'm kind of going through this and I'm
just going well why am I
going to pursue this
if it's not happening and we'll go
through all that have to go [__] see
her in court have to work on all this
other [__]
and so I just kind of like Let It Go and
never said
um
hey I know you're both people
never never that's why part of the
reason why I like but she stopped
contacting how long has it been knock on
wood well I had to make a lot of changes
I had to change lots of stuff personal
stuff stuff you didn't want to change
have to change like bank accounts have
to change you had to do all that yeah
because well because part of the thing
too is it's like
you get a thing from a t that could be
regular like hey you need your [__]
account was someone tried to hack your
account well that could just be like
some [__] dude you know like Ghana
like trying to [__] with you know what I
mean but also I'm like could be her
and that is kind of what happened so
you're on hold and you're everything is
just compounding your life is trying to
put out fires and um and so I had to
make a lot of [__] changes I have not
had Direct harassment since then but I
don't know how long has it been this was
probably about five years ago Jesus but
I've never gone I never showed up at a
local show or she's never gone as far as
to no because what I realized eventually
was this person has put herself into so
much
like legal Jeopardy that she has to be
really careful with what she does she
cannot do that she cannot she cannot
[__] up even though she did show up at
your show and take a picture yes but as
the other one but yes but that's when I
was dating her
you're already going out I wouldn't even
date her I was just like you know going
out with her but she did that as her all
these I'm not I mean all the fight club
stuff you're talking about like years
later like the Vegas shooting like I'm
like she wasn't in a [__] Vegas
shooting
God yeah I didn't even think of that
that's how she got me to give her that
number so that she knew that's how she
had the number so then she knew she
could [__] go crazy on me
and not wonder how she got my number
you know which eventually she probably
would have done anyway because she's
probably got like talk about wargaming I
mean she's probably got like choose your
own misadventions
but but all that stuff you know two two
years later I'd be like wait the [__]
that's [__] [__] you know imagine
she told me good news this is why I seem
so [__] stupid because I was buying
so much [__] she told me at one
point that while I'm going through all
this [__] with her a little bit a little
bit well I mean again like I was a
person that wasn't a person by another
real person
here's the difference I was like leave
me alone I was not like when can we meet
up I love you I was like [__] off like I
just wanted I was ignoring her I did
believe her to be real for sure and
again I'm like I now why wouldn't you
though me now
so different than that and I had friends
at the time who were like what are you
[__] simple like this is of course it
is but I had like my friend who's like
knows his [__] was like not the same
person I had it was just so Savvy that I
was like can't be crossed my mind for
sure but it just seemed so unbelievable
as deep in as I was that I was just like
campy cannot be and um
and then so as yeah and then eventually
so you know I just was like so rattled
that she's saying I know the GM of the
Packers
and I'm like huh she's like I can get
you tickets to a Packer game
I'm like really
wow look good she's helping me with her
and she's getting me got me Packer tick
and then I'm like wait she didn't know
the GM of the pack she was [__] she's
full of [__] she just like went to
Stubhub and she had she went on [__]
StubHub all this stuff I was able to
eventually like you know prove as I
built this case and stuff but that's
just basically where it it ended where I
basically was like okay whatever and
then a year later touring in Australia
again
and um someone text me
and goes
this dude
has been going out with your stalker
and I'm like oh my God it's another
comedian and I'm like do we know him do
I know yeah okay and we're I'm like oh
my [__] god and he's like it's like
Back to the Future or you know what I
mean where like Marty's like dude lesson
here she's like buddy I don't know who
you are but not me I'm from this time
I'm saying to him dude she's no no no no
no he's like no no she's I'm going buddy
I went through this she is that person
and that person and that person and that
he's going dude it's not she would have
to be out of her mind to do that I'm
like bad news she's out of her [__]
mind and and so as far as I know he that
situation ended too
and as far as I know it's like she's
still out there still going you know
probably still doing it
um just a parasite who moves from host
to host to host sometimes for people who
actually do host
you know like
countdown shows and stuff because it's
all industry related but um
but yeah and like I've I have been like
so hesitant to kind of like
talk about it because it's like because
it's gonna be out there again it's out
there
but it's something makes me doozy
spelled d-e-w-z-y
we'll be right back uh part of me makes
me feel bad for her though she was an
escort who gave it to you for free so
that's the part you feel bad for a
little bit
um but I want to know two questions
so everybody can understand this is a
hundred percent why I don't do this yes
okay listen I'm not a virgin I'm Not
Innocent yeah but I've had a lot of
writer producer jobs over the years and
those are where I tended to date the
ladies not ever in comedy or or randos
on the road or anything like that
um
was it worth it absolutely
[Laughter]
who are more famous than me who like do
this all the time and I'm just going
buddy
because you will like I know it feels
like a speed bump but man it is a
[__] bed of nails
that you do so is out there when you're
out on the road now are you much more
cautious
they call me they call me the Ryan
sickler stand up
you know I'll hug the older ladies and
stuff but those young cute ones that
come up I'll give you a hand what I do
is this is what I do if I'm gonna take
someone home I like want to see the
phone if it's a flip phone I'm like what
are you doing you want to go get a drink
also if you just come up to me after the
show and you want to bang me I know
there's something wrong with you it is
it's like what someone wants to run for
president you're like probably shouldn't
be president
now I want to think this story and be
like nah no you know what happened to
Gareth Reynolds I'll tell them that
story and scare them off they're like
I'm I'm [__] dry now yeah I'm like
yeah dude and then the other thing is
like dude when I'm going through the
thick of this I'm like on tour a lot I
was like I mean a part of me is like
reticent to talk about how much it
affected me because
it is I'm sure gratifying for her in
some way when she sees this or whatever
but I mean I was not eating I would have
morning sickness no joke
no joke morning sickness
I was the pregnant one I would like wake
up day of the show and I would be like
dry heaving
just be like
throwing up only time my brain kind of
got away from it was when I was
performing when I was doing shows when I
was like doing the podcast but like you
know I'd be at shows and I would be like
before it like looking at my phone and
my phone would be backstage I wouldn't
think about it I'd have like two hours
like if I'm doing the dollop or like an
hour if I was doing stand-up to not
[__] think but she know your
schedules dude and Texas you knew you
were on stage no come back well she knew
the day of shows Angela would [__]
blow me up
you know starting a website about you
hey I just pitched you uh for an article
because you're such a douchebag and you
like you know I sent them the DM
messages you had with me and it is crazy
the the so what is that split
personality bipolar what the hell is
that I really don't even know I I mean
just I I actually don't fully know what
I do know is that it's I mean obviously
it's sociopathic it's yeah there's a
borderline personality disorder for sure
but this is the sort of [__] that like
you know 20 [__] years ago if you
were like this you either followed
someone or you stalked them in a weird
way the internet and the laws that are
in place as far as this [__] goes are so
inadequate and do you feel like they
protect the stalker more absolutely yeah
without question I mean there is this
that
you are able to do this [__] with such
ease again I'm not saying like I'm a
[__] genius in this situation by any
stretch but you should not be able to
harass people from as many numbers as
you [__] want whether you [__]
create fake people or not like you
should just not be able to do that you
should be held accountable for these
things when I went to the [__] cops
and I'm like this is who's doing this
they didn't even want to engage in the
conversation about anything other than
how she looked and that's what I mean
when like I have like I don't even want
to say like empathy because
I just
the way that we think of people and how
they take trauma and compartmentalize it
and how they have to wait to feel
comfortable for it is totally
misconstrued and skewed and I was never
someone who's like well why why is she
coming out with the allegation 10 years
later but after this I'm like why would
she come out with the allegation
immediately you are in such and again I
my version of this is different but the
the paralyzation I felt throughout it
was one where it was like I couldn't
[__] get out of bed some days with
what was going on I was [__] losing
my mind losing my mind over this [__]
and and again this went on for just
under a year and so like I really do
look at it like you know a year of my
life was like kind of ruined because of
this and it's it's not as easy as me
being like hey
online harassment detective I'm filing a
case against this person go do it no
it's hey go get a private eye hey you
got the private eye
dude crazy you think lawyers are
expensive these [__] dudes are nuts
and pay that guy now pay a lawyer now
all that which to some extent again I
have done a lot of that in the long run
but um
but it just should not be that way you
are able to do this these people are
able to [__] harass the [__] out of
people and there's really very little
you can do and it's like that level of
how you feel when you're in the midst of
it I think people really understate how
that feels
I don't think I handled it right at all
I don't I don't know that there's a
right way to handle something like this
who the hell is gone I can't imagine
many people have gone also you don't
feel like you're not like opening a town
it's almost like it's not real yeah you
know like and you don't want to be like
look at what my [__] dick got me into
you know what I mean you don't want to
be like everyone listen here's another
problem my penis cop you know you're
just like you're hiding it you're hiding
it you're [__] Sheltering it like
when my buddy at work told people that
was going on I was like why the [__] did
you do that because you just know people
are looking at you different and they
were they were like trying to help me
but I'm like I don't want to be looked
at like that and it and it was just like
it just changed me on a level that like
I'll never go back now I think she still
hits me up I think she still does stuff
on Instagram see another uh profile you
think it might be her I know now what's
[__] you know yeah that's things it
doesn't even matter if I know it's
[__] I don't engage in that world
anymore you can't
it's like your internet you're right
it's before when you were crazy you had
to put that crazy out there or at least
hide it long enough you had to be like
trash sniffing now you can yeah now you
can just hide that craziness Forever on
in the digital world yes and then you
look at this person's Instagram and
they're like it looks normal yes but
then you're like no good day at the
pumpkin patch you're like you [__]
psycho you texted me from 800 numbers
that day
you know Gareth Reynolds first of all
I'm glad you're okay glad I have no STDs
here I do five yeah
you're not listening ah
something to cherish her forever yeah
they'll leave behind the calling card
what a wild story that I've never heard
anything like that yeah have you well
you no I I mean I want to know who this
is we're done I wanna know who this is
and who else she dated because I want
people I want to know we got to look out
for this lady she's in our world
I I don't know right now how active she
is but I mean I you know like I said I
mean it's even if it's not just her this
is [__] out there they're like the
people she went for were people that she
was fans of she just like listen to my
podcast or she watched this TV show and
she liked this guy or whatever the [__]
it was it's it's that morphed into I
want to control their lives ruin it ruin
the troll yeah ruin it yeah but be able
to um like you know run an emotional
Symphony when I feel like conducting
right and um and yeah I mean that's like
if there's one thing that you could take
from it it's just [__]
don't be like Gary be [__] smart be
like Gary bro just be like don't let
your dick do your thinking no yeah no
it's no pun intended hard yeah no and it
was
hard damn dude yeah I told you I had a
[__] dude you sure did have a doozy
yeah but I just like couldn't like
this was like the place where I'm like
because part of me is like I should be
doing stand-up on some of this but I
just have never told it you know you do
have to tell it
I have to to some extent because it's
like the craziest traumatic thing of and
the other thing you know who was amazing
during this time there were a few people
who were amazing one of the people who
ran the Facebook group was amazing Dave
Anthony just kept being like he just
kept being like this is a person
shouting in a closet because I would see
the stuff going on my Twitter feed and
he'd be like it's not as bad as you
think that's why she had to amplify it
with DMS but Dave just kept being like
it's a crazy person shouting in a closet
so
so there you go that's why um
stay single
um plug and promote everything again
please uh I'm looking to hook up with
women on the road uh so I can slide into
my DMs whenever you're ready yeah if
you're mentally stable mentally unstable
let's roll the dice that's what I'm
after my new special roll the dice uh
premieres on Unsolved Mysteries uh next
Thursday uh go check that out
um also I'm actually now selling a very
a chlamydia pill
um which is unbelievable most of these
things you got to go through a much
stronger cycle of antibiotics these
things bang them out in two days that's
why it's called the round of applause
get that
promo code Michelle 1l unless two if
you're texting
um
no go listen I mean listen to the dollop
uh I have a another podcast I'm starting
with my buddy Jake Johnson uh called
we're here to help which uh if you go to
my Instagram there's an email where you
can message problems it's like an
old-timey call-in show and then uh my
specials garethrowns.com click the
special link there's gareths which is
crowd work there's England weed and the
rest which is a pure stand up a little
crowd work and then tour dates care of
thrones.com
and then and then the dollops on the
road in the Past Times yeah go to go to
dollarpodcast.com we're on the road in
August when this comes out and the Past
Times you're not gonna acknowledge that
I gotta correct there
for the release date bro you said when I
got it right who knows when this will
come out uh as always guys thank you
very much Ryan sickler on all social
media Ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign